the president the sitting president the
current president made it clear today he
intends to keep fighting the results
of this election even if biden should be
projected as the winner
the mayor of philadelphia today was not
dancing over that
know i think what the president needs to
do is frankly put his big boy pants on
he needs to acknowledge the fact that he
lost and he needs to congratulate the
winner
just as jimmy carter did just as george
h.w bush did
and frankly just as al gore did and stop
this and let us move forward as a
country
put your big boy pants on i think
someone should have said that to donald
trump a long time ago look there is
precedent
for how someone is expected to act after
an
election defeat and guess what acting
like a petulant toddler
isn't it when mitt romney lost to barack
obama in 2012
he called and conceded this is a photo
of president obama
taking that call today senator romney
said trump's false claims of a rigged
corrupt and stolen election
damages the cause of freedom here and
around
the world the last one-term president
george h.w bush left a letter behind on
the resolute desk
for the successor who defeated him
democrat bill clinton it said that his
success would be the country's success
and bush told clinton quote i am rooting
hard for you
america believes in the peaceful
transition of power
the nation watched as the second
president bush
hugged michelle obama yeah hugged her
before helicoptering away from the
capital
on the day of the inauguration in 2009
and by the way he reappeared at the
inauguration of donald trump a man who
trashed him practically daily
on the campaign trail to be fair he was
also overheard saying after trump's
speech that day
that was some weird excrement
but you have to wonder will trump turn
up to bidens if indeed biden is
confirmed as the winner will he turn up
to biden's inauguration
look rituals are important symbols are
important the handoff
from one president to another assures us
that in the american democratic
experiment
there will be a peaceful transition of
power
that there is nothing to fear but no
today we had to settle for the biden
campaign telling us
it was prepared to escort donald trump
out of the white house on january 20th
if it comes to that those are fighting
words
we should never forget that none of this
is normal
the law and order president is abusing
the law
and has no interest in order so where
does this end
where does it end